merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
monsieur le ministre les connaissances
les connaissances des jeunes entrant en
4e en 2023 ont fait l'objet d'une
évaluation nationale portant sur 7039
établissements et 795000 collégiens
celle-ci montre un effondrement sans
précédent de leur niveau cela fait dire
à nombre de nos concitoyens que la
France est entrée dans une régression
éducative continue qui risque de faire
de nous une nation dilétré si tel est le
cas que va-t-il advevenir de notre
démocratie nous sommes à quelques jour
de la publication des résultats
internationaux PISA sur l'évaluation de
la performance des systèmes éducatifs et
nombre d'observateurs s'inquièteent de
la place de la France dans ce classement
le système éducatif a vu se développer
des ramifications toujours plus
nombreuses dans les programmes scolaires
le développement des enfants doit être
pensé de manière globale cependant nous
ne pouvons laisser nos enseignants
devant des jonction contradictoire si
nous admettons que le français et les
mathématiques sont des savoirs
fondamentaux prioritaires nous ne
pouvons continuer à refuser de
hiérarchiser nos enseignements si chaque
élève ne dispose pas des compétences
fondamentales en matière de français de
mathématique et de lecture il est à
craindre que l'ensemble des efforts sur
les temps scolaires et périscolaires ne
soit avoué à l'échec le défi de notre
société comme en santé et ailleurs et
notre capacité à former plus rapidement
qualitativement et tout au long de la
vie professionnel vous avez annoncé un
effort de votre ministère en matière de
formation des enseignants considérant à
juste titre que cette formation devait
être hors temps scolaire monsieur le
ministre quelle disposition concrète
prévoyez-vous pour accompagner le
développement professionnel des
enseignants afin de permettre à notre
nation de retrouver la place qui devrait
être la sienne en matière
d'apprentissage et de maîtrise des
fondamentaux
scolaires je vous remercie est monur
Gabri ministre de l'éducation nationale
et de la
jeunesse merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député
alfondar depuis
1987 mon ministère le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale fait passer la
même dictée à un panel représentatif des
élèves de CM2 en 1987 il y avait en
moyenne 10 fautes nous sommes
aujourd'hui à 20 fautes en moyenne en
1987 il n'y avait que 6 % des élèves qui
faisaient plus de 25 fautes nous sommes
aujourd'hui à près de 30 % en 1987 il y
avait près de 15 % des élèves qui
faisaient moins de deux fautes nous
sommes à peine à plus de 1 % aujourd'hui
oui il y a une baisse du niveau il faut
la regarder sans phare il faut le dire
et surtout il faut y répondre le point
positif des évaluations qui ont été
rendues à la rentrée c'est qu'on voit
qu'un investissement massif et des choix
politiques permettent d'inverser une
tendance la réalité c'est que le niveau
des élèves qui rentrent en 6e cette
année s'améliore par rapport au niveau
des élèves qui entraient en 6e en 2017
très concrètement on voit que sur le
français et les mathématique il y a une
amélioration du niveau parce qu'on a
réinvesti massivement est-ce que c'est
suffisant non il faut aller beaucoup
plus loin et vous l'avez vu j'ai ouvert
un certain nombre de chantiers j'aurai
l'occasion de faire des annonces la
semaine prochaine j'assume de le dire
laissz passer au collège un élève qui ne
sait ni lire ni écrire ni compter cela
relève d'une forme de
maltraitance laisser entrer au lycée un
élève qui accumule un tel retard ça
n'est pas possible j'aurai l'occasion
d'annoncer des mesures fortes sur le
sujet dès la semaine prochaine pour cela
j'ai beaucoup échangé avec l'ensemble
des acteurs éducatifs je veux saluer le
travail qui est conduit à l'Assemblée
nationale par Annie jeunevard et Fabrice
l vigoureux dans la mission qu'il
réalise sur la question de la lecture
oui nous devons nous interroger j'ai eu
l'occasion de le faire sur la place du
redoublement sur des groupes de niveau
au collège pour permettre enfin de faire
progresser tout le monde sur le soutien
qui apporté à nos enseignants je vous
donne rendez-vous la semaine prochaine
pour annoncer mon plan d'élévation du
niveau général nous le devons à nos
élèves et nous le devons à notre pays
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre